-I want talk about something
you write about your book.
You write about your passion
for picking up garbage.
-Well, because we live in --
I live in England now.
-Yeah.
-And I didn't notice it
in London so much,
but then we moved to West Sussex
in a little village.
It's in
the South Downs National Park.
And so the downs are like
these massive hills
that are so green
they make your eyes ache.
And we live on a, you know,
a narrow one-lane road.
And so if two cars are coming,
one has to pull off.
and, like, a cottage
that looks like a storybook.
But people throw everything
out the car window.
Everything. You finished with
that newspaper?
Throw it out the window.
Coffee cup? Throw it out
the window.
Sandwich?
Throw it out the window.
And when I moved there,
I wrote -- and I said,
"Is there a parade?"
Like, I couldn't conceive.
And every...So I had a meeting
and was proposing
a bunch of things,
and they said,
"No, we can't. No, we can't."
So I just thought,
"Okay fine, I'll do it."
[ Laughter ]
So it's -- it's like
an 8-hour a day job.
-Uh-huh.
-And I have an outfit,
and I pick up trash
for eight hours a day.
-And you've written that
it's actually not that bad.
You listen to a podcast.
You listen to...
-Yeah.
I just think of it as my job.
But people see me, and they just
think that I'm crazy.
I mean, they...
-Yeah.
-If I come upon a family,
they pull their children close.
They...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, because usually, people,
in order to do what
you're doing,
have had
to have committed a crime.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
No, a lot of people think
that I'm a felon and...
I have a grabber.
-Uh-huh.
-And I have...I mean, when I
say I have an outfit, like,
they want me to wear
this reflector, but I'm not.
-Yeah.
-It's more like
a hobo outfit that I wear.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Like with big patches,
like a Broadway --
if there was a Broadway play
called "Hobo,"
that's what I'm dressed like.
-But now, this has not
gone unnoticed.
They actually --
I guess the town --
is it the town that gave you --
bestowed this honor?
They named a garbage truck
after you.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is true.
This is the Pig Pen Sedaris
garbage truck.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, because...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well...
they were gonna put my name
on it, and I thought,
"Well, 'Sedaris' on a garbage
truck just wouldn't make sense."
And I don't really have
a nickname.
I always wanted one.
And you can't really
give yourself one.
So I thought, "Okay, Pig Pen,"
so it'd just have pig on it...
-Yeah.
-...and then make it
a little bit better.
-These -- By the way,
these couldn't look
more like what I pictured
British women who come
to this kind of ceremony.
[ Laughter ]
Everything.
-The local paper
did an article about it.
The article was just like,
"Local man picks up trash."
-Uh-huh.
-And then someone in America
saw it and said,
"Don't you know who this is?"
And so they rewrote it.
But it doesn't matter...
-Yeah.
-...that I'm an author.
It doesn't really matter.
-No, that's not what
this is about.
-No.
-I have to ask,
in your trash picking up,
have you seen that newspaper
article on the ground yet?
[ Laughter ]
'Cause that would really --
that's, like,
circle of life right there.
You actually were invited to
speak to the House of Commons
based on
your trash proclivities.
-I went and I testified to the
House of Commons about litter.
-What did you testify about?
Just litter?
-Well, it was me and the head
of the tobacco manufacturers,
and a guy --
a woman who owns, like,
eight McDonald's franchises.
And when it was my turn, I just
said, "I'm not -- I'm nobody.
"I just pick up rubbish,
and here's what I pick up
and here's what I notice."
But it never occurred to me that
anyone would be for litter.
-Uh-huh.
-But one of the MPs was just,
"So, Mr. Se-dah-ris..."
Like -- Oh, maybe he said,
"Mr. Se-dah-ris,"
as if, like,
that's not really my name.
"You live in Horsham,
a very wealthy...
"[ Clears throat ]
part of the country.
"So tell me, sir,
"is somebody throwing a can
out their car window
the biggest problem
you have down there?"
And I'm just not used to being
talked to that way, you know?
-Sure.
-And I was just flustered.
But for the rest of my life,
I'll resent saying --
I'll be mad at myself
for not saying, "Oh, God, no.
"No, no, no.
The biggest problem
is your mother's whoring."
[ Laughter and applause ]
What would they...
[ Cheering ]
what would they --
what would they do?
I mean,
they couldn't imprison you.
-You know, I think if
you said that,
you'd be back in the newspaper.
[ Laughter ]
-But who's for trash?
-Yeah, who's for litter?
-Who is for it?